I want the 2024 Republican primary to
become the dirtiest
filthiest most corrupt and disgusting
mud-slinging Fest that we can imagine
because it will be bad for republicans
in 2024 and we already read of trump
going after Ron DeSantis as being fat
and phony and whiny but Ron DeSantis is
also now going after Donald Trump
there's a great article by Gabriel
Sherman and Vanity Fair Gabriel Sherman
is very good at these types of Articles
the article is called Ron DeSantis the
making and remaking and remaking of a
Maga air with the subtitle the Florida
governor is the fox loving lib owning
successor in waiting to Donald Trump's
cult of personality but for all
desantises Bona fides and rocketing
National profile doubts about his own
Persona calculated aloof cold-blooded
persist is it any wonder he and the
former president are already locked in a
2024 Cold War
the article explains
that behind the scenes
uh Ron DeSantis is not a big fan of
Donald Trump and I have to tell you Ron
DeSantis is not a dumb guy I think Ron
DeSantis is completely depraved morally
ethically and his willingness to take on
the Persona that he has taken on as
Florida Governor rubs me obviously the
wrong way I think it's immoral and
disgusting but the truth is DeSantis is
not stupid he's a highly educated guy
and it's hard to believe that DeSantis
would genuinely see Trump in a positive
light obviously desante sees Trump as a
[ __ ] and that is exactly what this
article says to santis is saying behind
the scenes the article says so far the
DeSantis Trump's Smackdown has been
unfolding off camera but it likely won't
stay that way DeSantis and private
trashes Trump he calls him a TV
personality and a [ __ ] who has no
business running for president a former
DeSantis staffer said
DeSantis tells donors that if he takes
on Trump he would launch a full frontal
attack on his record incompetence
according to a republican Source briefed
on the conversation DeSantis says the
only way to beat Trump is to attack him
head-on he would he says he would turn
to Trump during a debate and say why
didn't you fire fauci you said you would
build the wall but there's no wall why
is that
sandis is not stupid okay my interest is
that both of these guys go down in
flames in 2024. so I say let him fight
I've been saying this for a while the
more
Trump hurts DeSantis the better the more
DeSantis hurts Trump the better at some
point one of these two is going to be
the front runner and whatever hits they
take from the other guy are going to
extend the Republican primary make it
uglier and hopefully turn people off of
voting from voting for Republicans
altogether
DeSantis has taken a lead in the betting
markets these are extraordinary numbers
now I want to remind everybody this is
not polling of who do you support this
is betting who do you believe will
eventually be the nominee DeSantis is
now leading Trump
this has not been the case for a while
and in fact if we look at the uh 90 day
let's see what are the numbers here
uh yes you see that sometime in early to
mid-august DeSantis equaled and then
surpassed Trump trump sort of came back
a little bit but now it is DeSantis
steadily in the lead in the betting
markets if you want to make a dollar
betting on Trump being the nominee
you've got to bet 29 cents and if you
want to make a dollar betting on
DeSantis being the nominee you've got
about 35 cents in other words since it
is considered more likely at this point
in the betting Market that DeSantis will
be the nominee you've got to put up more
money to make a dollar this is a really
big deal the SanDisk is building a lead
here now in terms of the behind the
scenes if I were to sandus I would be
trying to for for example maybe expedite
the investigations into Trump into
sandus's own State of Florida remember
Mar-A-Lago Trump's home is in Florida I
would be trying to secretly screw Trump
over by making the legal trouble as bad
as possible now maybe to see dentist is
doing that but you have the Republican
Party having to walk what is essentially
a tightrope they can't turn on Trump
right now without losing Trump
supporters and it's too early for that
because Trump May indeed run
at the same time if they're too aligned
with Trump they risk going down with the
ship if Trump indeed gets indicted and
goes down and someone like the scientist
really Builds an actual polling lead
against Trump many of these presidential
elections even though the elector of the
popular vote difference is big I mean
millions and millions of votes that Joe
Biden won by in 2020 oftentimes the
Electoral margin comes from narrow
victories in just a handful or even two
or three states so it is a very fine
line that these Republicans are walking
my view as a concerned leftist is Let
Them Fight
let him fight and let him make it as
filthy as possible
I often have a very hectic schedule and
I don't always have the time to plan the
exact nutrition of all of my meals but
our sponsor athletic greens just makes
it easy to make sure I'm getting the
nutrients I want I've been using it for
almost a year now and it's great ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious
plant-based blend of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics from
whole food sources if I have just one
small scoop of ag1 a day I know I'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
I want that support all of the things
that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day I'm not doing that I don't want to
do that ag1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie I drink it straight
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make AG one part of
your daily routine the way I have done
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs the
link is down below